The
next excerpt is
also taken from original tape W one forty
eight
in this so I think the story of the
play there was this girl she was very
ugly and you know she did him nobody care for
her. She never been the I'm nothing like
that she just she just was I think to just to ugly.
You know for someone to care for her.
I think something like that.
Never happened but if you
read about her brother who
has
never
seen my family or I
come school in the
morning and I see these
boys you know they call in Sacramento to a dinner a day later
after somebody comes and say to this boy like
you see I use the good this
boy his name
is you know. So in my own when she went with
a boy
to it so we tried to see we didn't know how to time boy.
So we tried it so we went with two boys and I'm side of town and two boys were related.
So one night. Boys another side of sound came over to my
house and me and her were in a to avoid that Denise you. Was
there and they getting to doing it after me so I came
to get what I came to the
door and this lead to this place that could a
community. I've seen and I just done that I'm in the hole but don't let this I said
I rather come out
why I said to my bus iness my father come
so gratified.
But they went out the
front. And we went out the sex with other boys while they
were down the hill and we was really just talking in touch with that
so then we went to my friend's south.
So we went over there to let the boys out there was it would be a
bet with down the judges see who we could
do and
so he said first to come up like so we thought that
they didn't do a thing which one you want me to you.
I asked are studying the open to stuff like that and I
said at that hour he was like that nice. OK so
this one is a stew. He's another
real nag and he liked me a
lot so I went I went
there at the top of the black go he will home on the bus.
So I went up there and I asked his brother where was he in how
I would be doing. You see get T. is common as as us and no you don't.
That's a good term story. They said no I'm NOT GO
think so he had told me that if I ever was to do something
real badly in that it was. And he had tears in his that so I don't believe you cited when
and only when
they lack a lot of boy I went with.
His awful tone is quit and went back with him and now and then.
I quit him. And now I think that
they're still lacking the he still like me but he still remembers the time
was when you know when I took time him and he get a disconnect for
getting that for thirty years mostly getting he was to go back and really
don't know whether I'd do it again and
I think you know. I'm trying to know
why. You know where when you break up with so much when you go with to war the think
that you know maybe real men feel like they want to be to us and I call it going big
me that it want to be like this that's why
him. He was on to another
boy and I've got to move. I went over to see about her name still
I mean you see learned she
said who I were you remember you.
I think the same got nothing to do do not end up money Bill
mom and she said Who do you think I said I said both people either
when I think where all my
stuff like that the sedition live a clear message to say
yo I sit in there with the two was already a
mirror there was Ivan who wanted her and I think that would be good.
She was supposed to pay it.
So he did pick them one if he wanted then they broke up.
They have a back for
see the group. We have a ball boys and a group of girls there
are more boys than girls.
So a girl is a is the president in a boys of biases and sixty.
So these are the rules we get with
the Garcias big boys the
guys offices got a size
and now we have the service with children that we go and have on leave in the
States so that is the ministration
business. Is it to do with Chichi comes out
the teeth in the loo good
man and they let us use the death even non-SI say.
Tina don't like
that and so. Last night we had a meeting.
He stated he can't come to LA to mean that you have to be put out and if you can't.
And if he can't get to mean hard time then stay out the
same as long as they can't be in it.
And you know if you come if you come real made you
know not unless you have a good reason. That's not coming from
relate
to God can take you
and can take you. And then do some TS That would work. I think is the too
up not dead zone over vanished you know not a good deal.
The president a
developer and you get put out for a month and then you can come
back and then the vices and he made a brand name first who
currently grits and does a while back just a girl with a boring.
Nigger say we did this with five girls five or.
The anger out all the time was getting serious. You always got my house because their
mothers came in a lot and had too much company. So we used to have while I meet the
by house and then when you want to go out we go at midday
say
if somebody One mother says no then all the rest
leave us from the high. So I go out and have a good time to come back till
necessary to see if we can go together.
And I see one time
I was going to get his shoes and
I saw one girl and had the money so we waited until she got her money then all of
us you know we had issues we had parents in the in the sweat is nothing alike.
We just go around boys and boys they hang around together
where you know if we
are not separate where we go together to see the boys that we like and we go
with
this like this and now we have this cousin Dick tease with the boys and
girls together to get
ts. Taking in a
T.V.. It's kept T.V..
And he does have a lot of learning. You did you
know we was going to name the mighty corruptors but for my
L. he had got that to leave him.
He does have a lot of when you know when the
boys see the boy we had a treasure when the boys are in girl. You can't
go out by yourself you get to go with them you don't have to go the whole club but.
They've gone to one family living
close but it's one like
the show or something like that to go to show with the
boys in clubs like this but one thing I don't want to go with some. When
I
know somebody at one of my other boyfriends
and you know if I am well aware line I like
me but realistic again and yet
not like what we do
we go we go
I go to the club buys.
We go
downtown to put some money together like.
Went downtown and I put my money in he put his money in I don't leap in the
shoes. And he does this one
yes
he got to meet you know we put our money together we get a
moment. He's a Catholic boys
carry higher than the other girls going
to be in the shoes like
boys where you know we
go to my house for
men go my half of hair leave the reader make a lot of fuss and when
I wake up my
mother the descent with the cookies is so
denied because the do
I enter there we go outside. We see little
kids fight a little and then a fight it is great get a big let me tell him the goal of the son
is in the in the kid is go tell the mother like
that in the mother do something from you know we are never done.
Nobody
is nice to the people because a lot of
are there because they think they
are there or that this is their last.
We talk about what we're going to do the next day. What we're going to
we're we're going we're see if we want to go to a backboard
game something like that you raise them. You know who P.S. with the Coke reject to go
to it.
And you have to have the you don't have
to but you know the girls like they have the same kind of shoes and
the boys they can come
visit but you can't you have to stick around
with a little in a tailor's. Issue with to the game
and. How we should. You know sometimes lose
do
it like come on and you know me
see I got
as. I kissed a Away back of my leg you know side does walk like
that icon of my fiancee Rhonda good
to see the actress. Defeating bananas a straw seal buses
a
baseball. He did next to get upset that
we say we believe in is all just really strikeouts we
just say around work around the circle go to the
store like it is for real
and mean we're up.
And see really is it just sit and taught
well what about you know what are we going to do
is school in you have to this is a rule. Yes Do we work in
every class because there's always somebody I notice in the club this in my class and if
you don't do you work you get in trouble.
You know you have a
twenty minute class there then
is not my club or. One of my club member board no reading
I really did tell
him some of them I would say you know you had to have good grades. You know
be good for the people you dislike that relate
to the talk about my. And you get
them Are they can get on about
this and it's getting to go a lot bigger than it is good know
that if we pull up play records.
Sometimes we go out
and go to these churches. And they
are the last ones to drink not strong
and
soda. Like their.
Drink like that to
get back.
Or I asked. The first one if that song
was that we have a crisis we hang around so much to
get by us
is that the wrong realizes haven't looked
close to the girl you know disliked
them. So you
know. We first of all quite
a mother says you know we could sing a little bit not that
much. The need to
get back together that we ran
aground and see the boys play basketball and hear the
name and it is another one with the girl and then the boys want to get
whatever police are in there about the business by
the sectarian
guys and sides in the end by really going on trial.
You know if you do something to put your arms around.
No way it could be staff or home month and you know is there
because a lot of the regatta when you
get back to there around the place somebody
else just came out like the never the
chance at my vote leave the
out with this granny go places and my
sister my sister can drive my mother's crack and turn my
little take take us
nowhere in it.
We're
sorry we. Well
see to see
some
stuff from up out of Afghanistan for the bull I know we talk about a whole bunch of serious stuff
you know we've talked about how May no ground fight no other close. You know we
did invite him when I've been ill and make a whole bunch of new friends and know
maybe somebody new moves out
there you know we get to nominate thing in Aspen in one being a clear
winner and I get we we just have a little media
and anyone ever tried it out.
No we did being in the gallery No
you never know trouble. We'll just see we
make friends with them chanting you know. So Mike Morwood
is a kook up isn't like that when you tell me Go
raise your missile in a missile or an
idea see if it's a girl
we go meet him is the boy and a boy and believe in a repeat girl
know if you know C.C. you know C.T.
to prison isn't like that they don't want to hearing Mallalieu my neighbors.
So is she there are we to
argue it is like you know to live want to come out
sign yet that a come out side
of oil want you to come in house on it like
get you to China when you know he's good to us
and take a vote on illegal
immigrants. We don't have because this is more boys and girls and he does that
five
girls now in seven men with seventy eight boys.
The more there's more than one of the guards
we can plan to Saigon leave the union and fight when you
lose the number one.
Because
we read about credit is this social science.
None of it. None of the people in our club is places
and when you have got a
relevant nobody's
been she is not new you know you can't progress. If you don't
have too much then you will act but if you have a lot you know they say she is she and
I
don't like
you know exactly right.
But when I teach like if it is the
pseudo watching going to win and I get nothing on my T.V. dinner President No they
have a reason for them not to let you go to elaborate like this in a sea of some I want to go
to was
bound in and if you let the person go everybody else is going to want to go
so those in it then that person think
that he's printed it let one go and a little nervous a
little explain a little girl.
So he decided to include where you come in and drink it when the the lab is the best
way
you know maybe even let it happen
because some some kids or know you did they don't want to get plenty of
books and not like that they don't work there for something they eat. Yesterday you know
when you were and then you can
schooling be generous and give all items and she did you give her some and then the next day she been certainly
she'd only give you
know mostly just she didn't want she
could sit down and pray she. Only Want to give what everybody else to give her
son she doing you know
to the one
I'm
not the same to me now you know I'm gonna lead by saying Well son
you know he's my Mossad again and
when my mother got a head the lady used to live I as he was like they used to
drink coffee and have cooked business single leader with
our grandmother. You know my mother didn't think they're right
people in those cases they just don't like to
see because people white people fight. You know they see the white people get no getting the
best of the color and then they want to jump in it too but I won't do
it if they did it and come across a study you know with the right
business to fight a bit no bison just been issued. They started
it
and it wasn't going to
cry on them at all you know how they
probably did because the girl was they told me this isn't the girl was
a you know to kind of religion that you can't sing songs or something like
that just over with seven or she can sing the song is coming down
to the right book a
moving truck on a big and the last you who was singing you know
it looked like she was hitting a bus you resist stepping on a baton and when I see this thing. And so
my chemo readings when they hit her in on it she didn't ask to go away. It was a thing
you knew this
was no medicine. You
know that it's Want to take this one a chance so that the Coca-Cola Company
went but they
don't because on our web we give
back. You know have to be so hoping to have to be so mean to
what you know a lot of kids say they hate white people an idea really hated their
family that would give them a hang around we don't
want this state it to be safe
for me and you is the magic white we got a white
boy Knuckle
Up here I dislike God so I'm not going
to
know
it is.